not the opinion of others that bother me  it's the opinion of myself  so are there any strategies for blocking  out the negative opinion  oneself can have about themselves  absolutely either your mother or your  father  put that negative opinion about yourself  in your head once you realize that  that's  true then you stop [ __ ] on yourself  and realize somebody else made you do  that  and you start the process of loving  yourself  we are not born to think we suck it is  instilled  in the insecurities or negativities of  the  people around us and by the way this  doesn't mean you should hate your  parents  they were doing that because that  happened to them but you need to  understand that that voice is not in  your head